what I want you to take that camera and
go out to Los Feliz Boulevard and walk
along the floor the room yeah and see
how many leaves are and see how many
plastic bags are okay do you know this
shop do you know the plastic bags only
make up 1% 1 to 2% of the litters the
river you want to go out to the river
with me I'll show it to you
in plastic bags you faithful
transporters of groceries line or as a
bathroom trash cans pickers up of dog
crap inspirers of late 90s Hollywood
screenwriters you've been banned banned
by the Los Angeles City Council but why
hey it's Kennedy for recent TV here at
LA City Hall I'm gonna go in and ask
some City Council members that very
question and I'm gonna be honest I'm
feeling a little fiery today I live next
to the ocean and you know what there's
all sorts of stuff going into the ocean
are you gonna make every single thing
illegal you're gonna make bad choices
and condoms
no condoms all over the street very good
there come on into committee right now
so councilmember alarcón why you so mad
at this sweet plastic bag what bag do -
you did nothing to me nothing to me it's
just that I think we can move beyond
that and move us in a direction that's
better for our environment the question
is will banning plastic bags that you
get in the grocery store actually do
anything to improve the water quality or
to the amount of garbage that's in the
oceans the answer is no the fact of the
matter is that in all the studies that
have been done that plastic bags that's
over all plastic bags only make up about
two percent of what they find
yeah maybe small in some people's eyes
but when you're looking at 1% that's a
huge difference no it's actually
minuscule compared to the other 99%
I don't compare it to the other 99% I
compared to what we've been looking at
the bigger picture no we should be
looking at all the pictures this is just
feel-good legislation it's not actually
going to do anything it's not gonna
solve any problems but it makes people
think that we've done something
councilman parks you were the only one
the bravest soul who voted against the
plastic
no I think I'm just the only one they've
read the ordinance is several years ago
when there were people that basically
had to get rid of paper because they
said it was saving trees never thought
about what plastic was gonna do years
later and I think we're in the same boat
today they were saying okay get rid of
plastic but we clearly are not thinking
about whatever is replacing it even if
you washing the bags and you do it just
as people say they still saying you
shouldn't not ever home Ingle them
you're gonna end up having to have a raw
meat bag a fish bag a fruit bag a
grocery a basically a vegetable bag are
you gonna end it instead we're gonna
back their own groceries are you gonna
sit over the the bag or shoulder and
tell them part of the reason I think
that this has passed is because the
people that are pushing this are very
powerful in terms of the number of
people that they can generate calls and
letters and things like that the general
population was not calling for a ban on
plastic bag we're changing the culture
of society making it more aware of the
environment more aware over you know
where is this one thing but government
forcing people to do these things we're
sure that we're not forcing them they
have an option they now have to pay for
because you know we're going to be
issuing bags the 22 pound bags that we
are calling sounds heavy my shoulders
can handle that well we will help you
with that
you don't have to load the bag to
capacity but if you do it's 22 pound
capacity and we're just changing the
weight for LA with its budget shortfall
has the money to give everybody
recyclable bag partner sanitation and
the stores are getting together and
there will be a number of base so we
distributed if I told you that there was
a product that I could that I could
provide to you in which you could take
your groceries home from the store that
80% of the people will reuse it the
people who don't reuse it
it's 100% recyclable do you think that
the City Council will fall all over
themselves mandating that we use that
product they probably would of course
I'm talking about plastic bags I do
support it I did vote for it but I was
on the author of it and I think if you
talked to the officers you may get more
information that may say
for your questions but I do know
anything is ever going to satisfy this
burning councilman sighing what's
burning record because I went left
conference these things are bad we have
to get rid of ferret convinced that
they're bad and they don't want to hear
anything else hopefully we'll get to a
better place I mean that's the whole
thing but in in the short term what I
can say is we will have a positive
impact on the environment you know what
a better place is fewer laws and less
government intrusion I agree with you in
some scale but not this